china Calcula que su economía crecerá
alrededor de un 5% el año que viene es
un objetivo realista y conservador
fácilmente alcanzable y que no requerirá
de las enormes y antiguas inversiones En
infraestructuras el dato lo ha revelado
esta mañana el Primer Ministro licán
durante la apertura de la asamblea
nacional popular con un discurso de
marcado carácter económico y es que esa
es la prioridad actual alcanzar la plena
recuperación económica Después de tres
años muy complicados en los que se ha
juntado el coronavirus crisis en
sectores tan importantes como el
inmobiliario o la inestabilidad
internacional para conseguir esa
recuperación líquido la creación de 12
millones de empleos urbanos y el
estímulo del consumo interno todavía muy
castigado por la pandemia el otro dato
que se esperaba con mucha expectación
esta mañana era el de el presupuesto
militar crecerá un
7,2% apenas una décima por encima del
año pasado a pesar de muchos analistas
pronosticaban una expansión mayor debido
a las cíclicas crisis con Taiwán o la
hostilidad creciente con Estados Unidos
Este ha sido el décimo y último discurso
de que chang frente a los casi 3000
delegados del Gran palacio del pueblo ha
durado menos de una hora mucho menos de
las duraciones estándares aquí en China
será la despedida discreta de un líder
discreto que no siempre ha estado en
sintonía con el presidente y que será
sustituido a final de semana por lichan
un Aliado cercano de sí